Google parent company alphabet is the latest
tech giant to trim thousands of jobs the
company announced its slashing six percent of its
Workforce Google's largest ever round of layoffs
follows recent cuts by Microsoft Amazon and meta
the parent company of Facebook Michael George has
been following the tech trim Michael good morning
Michelle good morning now some experts call this
a correction tech companies boom during the
pandemic over hired and now they have to adjust
to a post-pandemic economy but really there's
no way to spend this as positive more than ten
thousand people are suddenly finding themselves
unemployed alphabet the parent company of Google
is cutting 12 000 jobs about six percent of its
Workforce in an email the company's CEO wrote over
the past two years we've seen periods of dramatic
growth to match and fuel that growth we hired for
a different economic reality than the one we face
today the belt tightening at Google follows other
recent Tech sector job Cuts Microsoft announced
earlier this week it's laying off ten thousand
workers or nearly five percent of its Workforce
Amazon has said it's cutting 18 000 jobs and meta
the parent company of Facebook announced it's
laying off eleven thousand positions I think
that many companies are right sizing their
their staff many tech companies went on a
pandemic hiring spree because of increased demand
for their products as millions of people worked
remotely by late last year Google's parent company
alphabet said it had nearly 187 000 employees on
the books it is pretty easy for most companies to
cut 10 to 15 percent of their employee base right
now economists say what's happening in Tech is so
far an exception in the labor market the overall
labor market has been remarkably resilient the
latest data we have through December suggested
it is holding up despite higher interest rates
Isaac Del Rosario is a recently laid off software
engineer in Seattle I've been in the interview
hunt for about four months now Del Rosario is
finding job openings by looking outside of the
big Tech Giants surprisingly I've been able to
get interviews from more like smaller startups for
newly out of work software Engineers a job search
beyond the big name companies may be the way to
go and even with the new downsizing many of the
big tech companies are still bigger than they were
before the pandemic now laid off Google workers
will get a severance package of 16 weeks salary
plus two weeks for every year at the company
and it's important to note despite the massive
layoffs in Tech overall the nation's unemployment
rate last month was 3.5 percent that's a
50-year low Jeff Michael thank you very much